the Royals only hereos me
[Music]
Megan owes me what I've been through I
should be rewarded for Megan markle's
estranged father Thomas Markel speaking
out in the new documentary Thomas Markel
my story these 75 year old sat down with
Britain's channel 5 in October
participating in a series of interviews
over six days now ET is bringing you his
biggest revelations from the documentary
starting with this why Thomas says he
staged paparazzi photos before Megan's
2018 wedding to Prince Harry every paper
seemed to want to make me look like a
dumb fat slob I got approached by and a
guy named Geoffrey who spoke to me and
said I can change your image he said the
idea was that these will all be candid
shots discreet no one would know they
were posed or anything they it would be
just me doing my routine daily I was
feeling that this was very hokey and
hammy but he keeps saying you gotta
trust me
Thomas says he didn't do it for the
money even though he's still getting
paid I didn't do it for money I did this
to change my image you must still be
making money off the use of the pig
absolutely because those pictures will
sell forever
and now the Markel patriarch says he's
willing to do anything to exploit the
Royals and make a dime including getting
paid to do this documentary I don't care
I mean at this point they owe me
the Royals only my daughter told me that
when I reached my senior years she'll
take care of me I'm in my senior years
now I'm 75 years old so it's time to
look after daddy and now for a few of
our favourite one-offs like Thomas
admitting how he really felt about
Prince Charles walking his daughter down
the aisle on her wedding day
that was jealous Susan
I really wanted to do that I'll admit
that I cried a little bit about that he
also reveals how he's repeatedly tried
to get Megan to talk to him again
my deal was that I'd talk and do
something and wait 30 days to get a
response from Megan Harry if it didn't
get I didn't get a response I'd try it
again Thomas even explains why he
published the letter Megan wrote him
after her wedding in August 2018 the
same letter she and Harry are now suing
British tabloids over People magazine
had an article by Courtland quote
friends of Megan in this article the
Friends of Megan were saying that she
wrote a conciliatory letter to me she
was reaching out to me and trying to be
make peace with me and she was being
loving they dissed me calling me a liar
it seemed to me like it was set up I
thought I had to defend myself so I
published part of the letter Thomas also
reveals what he thought the first time
he saw images of Archie the first time I
saw pictures is when Harry carried him
outside for the first time so with as
much of Archie just that much or Archie
I hope he has my nose because then every
time they see Archie they want to see me
oh and here's this interesting side note
Thomas talks about the weirdest Sussex
memorabilia he's seen learn everything
you know I I actually heard that there
on the pack of condoms so I I don't know
that's true or not
Megan's finances are one final
conversation worth mentioning while the
Dutchess of Sussex claims she paid her
way through college at Northwestern
University
Thomas claims that's simply not true I
paid for college and it took me years to
get it paid off
- here was it I'm ghosted
I don't exist and she did this on her
own is very hurtful as for whether
Thomas thinks he'll ever talk to or see
Megan again the last time they might see
me is being loaded in the ground I don't
think at this point they're thrilled to
see me I want to talk to
[Music]